-Mon invitée n'a pas connu
l'Algérie française,
car elle est née
après son indépendance.
L'engagement de son père
dans l'OAS
a dû déterminer
beaucoup de choses dans sa vie,
peut-être même
son propre engagement en politique.
Générique
...
-Bonjour, Michèle Tabarot.
-Bonjour.
-L'engagement, chez vous,
c'est une histoire de famille,
avec votre père,
Robert Tabarot,
qui a mené un combat
pour l'Algérie française,
qui a pris
une forme radicale,
puisqu'il fut
l'un des dirigeants de l'OAS,
l'Organisation
de l'armée secrète.
Est-ce que vous auriez fait
de la politique,
si votre père était resté
le champion de boxe
qu'il a été, puis le vendeur
de pièces détachées de voitures ?
-Probablement pas,
car je pense
que nous serions restés en Algérie
s'il n'avait pas mené
ce combat.
Papa, qui était
très attaché à la France,
qui a souhaité protéger
les pieds-noirs, les harkis,
de tout ce qui se passait
pendant cette guerre terrible,
entre 1954 et 1962,
a souhaité s'engager.
Il avait un amour pour la France...
-C'est pour ça
qu'il mena ce combat.
-Absolument,
qu'il a mené ce combat.
Et puis aussi au nom
d'une certaine injustice,
car lorsqu'en 1958,
le général de Gaulle
vous annonce
que vous êtes en Algérie
et que l'Algérie
doit rester française,
être obligé de partir
4 ans après...
-Il s'est senti trahi ?
-Comme les militaires.
Des hommes épatants,
comme Hélie Denoix de Saint Marc,
qui avait été résistant,
à Buchenwald,
ensuite en Indochine,
n'a pas accepté,
comme beaucoup de militaires,
la raison du putsch.
On connaît mal l'histoire,
mais c'est une trahison.
Surtout, il y avait
des exactions, malheureusement,
et il fallait protéger
les pieds-noirs
et les harkis.
Papa s'est beaucoup battu
et nous a inculqué
à la fois cet amour
de la France,
ce respect
de la parole donnée,
et puis aussi ce lien indéfectible
entre les pieds-noirs,
entre les harkis
et entre l'Algérie.
-Ce combat politique
de votre père,
votre famille
en a payé le prix,
car après l'indépendance,
votre famille
n'a pas pu revenir en France,
parce que votre père
y était condamné pour terrorisme.
Vous vous êtes réfugiés
en Espagne,
à Alicante.
C'est là que vous êtes née,
que vous avez grandi,
loin de la France,
pendant presque six ans.
Quels rapports entretient-on
avec son pays
quand il y a
un tel contentieux
entre son pays
et sa famille ?
-C'était pas un contentieux
avec la France,
mais avec un pouvoir politique.
De Gaulle n'était pas
particulièrement apprécié
à la table,
lorsque nous évoquions
l'Algérie française...
-Vous ne l'avez pas vécu
comme une blessure avec la France ?
-Bien sûr, comme une blessure,
mais pas avec le pays.
La blessure,
elle a été énorme,
parce que quelque part,
j'imagine que lorsque
vous avez des enfants
et que vous avez envie
d'aller leur montrer
l'endroit où vous avez vécu,
tout ce qui fait leur histoire,
avoir la possibilité de retourner
dans son département,
c'est merveilleux.
Pour nous,
c'était quelque chose d'interdit.
Il a donc fallu recréer une vie
ressemblant à la France en Espagne,
créer l'école française,
ce que mon père a fait
avec les pieds-noirs
installés là-bas,
créer un journal pour pouvoir
informer les pieds-noirs
de ce qu'était la vie...
-A 5 ans,
vous avez été hospitalisée
en France.
Votre père n'a pas pu
vous accompagner
et aller à votre chevet
à l'hôpital.
-Absolument.
-Ca ne vous a pas fâché
contre la France ?
-Ecoutez, à ce moment-là,
je le comprenais.
On a été mûrs très tôt,
car on parlait librement de tout ça
avec nos parents.
Ma mère m'a accompagnée.
J'ai eu cette hospitalisation
pour un problème d'abcès au poumon,
donc j'ai été soignée
en France,
et mon père...
Voilà, il était...
Loin de moi,
mais il prenait
des nouvelles régulièrement.
Je le comprenais tout à fait
et je n'ai pas souffert
de cette absence,
car je la comprenais quelque part,
malgré mes 5 ans.
-Tous les membres de l'OAS
ont été graciés.
-Amnistiés.
-Votre famille est rentrée
en France en s'installant au Canet,
dans les Alpes-Maritimes.
Votre père fut
une figure importante
de la communauté pied-noir
sur place.
Vous-même, en 1983, je crois
que vous avez à peine 20 ans,
vous êtes élue
adjointe au maire du Canet.
Cinq ans plus tard,
c'est votre petit frère
qui est élu
conseiller municipal à Cannes.
Encore plus jeune !
Lui, il a à peine 18 ans.
Il est aujourd'hui sénateur.
-C'est ça.
-Ce double engagement
en politique,
est-ce que c'était
un peu une façon
de laver l'honneur
de la famille,
de venger votre père,
de prendre une revanche ?
-Bien entendu.
C'est en moi,
c'est très fort et...
et je comprends tellement,
et... je partage... cette douleur
qui est celle des pieds-noirs,
d'abord d'avoir été trahis,
ensuite d'avoir été accueillis
dans des conditions
assez difficiles,
car, en métropole,
on n'avait la vision
que de ces militaires
qui partaient,
et l'Algérie, c'était pesant,
il y a eu beaucoup de guerres...
Il n'y a pas eu la compassion que
les pieds-noirs auraient pu attendre
après ce drame, qui a touché
plus d'un million de personnes,
qui, après
plusieurs années de guerre,
se sont retrouvés
un petit peu éclatés
dans un pays
qu'ils ne connaissaient pas,
qui était leur mère patrie,
la métropole,
sans avoir jamais vécu en France.
-Pour comprendre,
vous vous engagez en politique
pour quoi ? Votre père l'a dit ?
-Non. Mon père nous a laissés
très vite.
J'avais... Premièrement, moi,
j'étais favorable et un soutien
de... Valéry Giscard d'Estaing,
en 1981,
Je fais la campagne, mon père aussi.
Il était actif en politique.
-Là, on vous voit adjointe...
-Voilà !
Exactement.
Et... Et donc,
je m'engage
pour la campagne 1981.
Ensuite, je suis tellement déçue
et affectée par la victoire
de François Mitterrand
que je décide de prendre ma carte
au Parti Républicain,
la droite non gaulliste de l'époque.
-Ainsi, vous vous lancez.
-On me propose
de rentrer au conseil municipal
du Cannet
et je deviens
adjoint au maire,
puis maire.
-L'histoire
familiale
est liée à l'Algérie.
Elle a resurgi
à l'Assemblée, en 2005.
Les députés débattaient
de la suppression
d'un article de loi
qui évoquait le "rôle positif"
de la colonisation.
Vous avez pris la parole
dans l'hémicycle.
C'était un peu
"au nom de tous les vôtres".
*-La France coloniale
a permis d'éradiquer...
a permis d'éradiquer
*des épidémies,
grâce aux traitements
dispensés
par les médecins militaires.
Les Français d'outre-mer
ont permis la fertilisation
de terres incultes et marécageuses,
la réalisation d'infrastructures
que les Algériens
utilisent encore aujourd'hui.
La France a posé les jalons
de la modernité, en Algérie,
en lui donnant le... les moyens
d'exploiter les richesses naturelles
de son sous-sol.
C'est ça, votre tolérance ?
-On le voit, vos propos
avaient déjà fait réagir
une partie de l'hémicycle.
Vous comprenez, aujourd'hui,
que ça puisse choquer, de défendre
le "rôle positif"
de la colonisation ?
-Je ne comprends pas,
qu'on ne comprenne pas...
-Vous restez...
-Je reste...
-...sur ce discours ?
Ce discours, vous pourriez...
-Je le tiendrais
aujourd'hui, oui.
Je... Je suis hors de moi,
lorsque je... relis
et lorsque j'entends les propos
d'Emmanuel Macron, en 2017,
considérant la colonisation
comme un crime
contre l'humanité.
Autant je ne souhaite pas
qu'on colonise
qui que ce soit d'autre,
aujourd'hui,
autant il faut bien comprendre
notre histoire :
l'Algérie a connu
la France
pendant 130 ans.
Les personnes qui étaient
nées là-bas... Mon père était là-bas
depuis 3 générations,
se levait
avec le drapeau français,
dans les écoles,
la Marseillaise...
-La colonisation
a aussi blessé...
-Je les entends...
Je les entends tout à fait.
Mais ce que je veux dire...
Ce qui s'est passé en Algérie
ne justifie pas
qu'on... qu'on ait ce sentiment
de culpabilité
vis-à-vis de la France.
On voit, aujourd'hui,
tout ça avec notre regard
d'aujourd'hui,
mais lorsque vous voyez...
eh bien, tous les...
Beaucoup de pays
ont eu des colonies,
ont apporté des choses positives,
des choses
qui l'étaient moins.
La France a quand même,
en Algérie...
Et on le voit, malheureusement,
l'Algérie, 60 ans après, est
dans un contexte politique
compliqué,
elle vit avec une dictature
qui n'a pas permis
à ce peuple exceptionnel,
avec lequel on a des liens
de fraternité et d'amitié,
de se développer
comme il le fallait.
Mais la France a laissé
des hôpitaux, des routes...
Maman était infirmière.
Elle a soigné des musulmans
et des européens.
Il n'y avait pas ce...
ce problème qui...
Il a peut-être été réel
chez certains,
mais la grande majorité
des pieds-noirs...
Albert Camus a dit
quelque chose de très beau.
Il a dit : "Ma famille..."
Et Dieu sait qu'il était,
dans les milieux universitaires
et dans les milieux gauchistes
qu'il pouvait fréquenter,
parfois attaqué là-dessus,
il l'a défendue à chaque fois,
en disant que...
que sa famille n'avait
opprimé personne.
Il faut bien réaliser
que la majorité
des pieds-noirs
se sont comportés en frères
avec les Algériens,
et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
qui fait que les harkis
ont été des combattants
aux côtés des Français,
parce que, eh bien,
il y avait ce lien très fort
entre les Français
et les Arabes.
-On va passer à autre chose :
le quiz. Vous avez droit
à une version spéciale
pour ce quiz.
Vous avez passé plus de 20 ans
à l'Assemblée.
Vous êtes
du genre à dire
"C'était mieux avant" ?
-C'était différent !
-Vous avez été députée-maire
15 ans : le cumul des mandats,
c'était mieux avant ?
-Oui. Je suis pour
le cumul des mandats.
Je pense que ça nous donnait
une grande liberté,
au niveau du gouvernement,
lorsqu'on est dans la majorité,
et au niveau
de l'opposition au gouvernement,
et de notre parti.
-Je pensais que vous diriez
"ancrage territorial".
-Ancrage, absolument.
Parce qu'ancrage territorial...
-"Légitimité" ?
-Une légitimité.
Lorsque vous êtes implanté
quelque part, c'est pas le parti
ou le gouvernement
qui va vous dicter les choses.
Vous jouez collectif,
bien entendu,
mais vous savez...
et le gouvernement et le parti
savent très bien,
que vous êtes enraciné.
-Vous siégez à l'Assemblée
depuis 2002.
Vous avez connu majorité
et opposition.
Diriez-vous que la vie politique
à l'Assemblée,
c'était mieux avant ?
-Pour moi, c'est différent.
J'ai vécu des périodes
passionnantes
avec la période
où Jean-François Copé
était président
de groupe. On faisait
de la coproduction législative :
on avait les parlementaires
qui étaient
totalement impliqués
et qui arrivaient
à pousser les lignes
du gouvernement.
Ca a déjà été le cas
pour un texte comme la burqa,
où c'est vraiment le Parlement
qui a porté ça et un peu obligé...
-Ca, vous trouvez
que ça fait défaut ?
-C'est une excellente chose,
aujourd'hui, depuis ce mandat.
On revit quelque chose
de positif
pour l'Assemblée :
c'est d'avoir une opposition
qui arrive
à se faire entendre...
-Grâce à la majorité relative.
-Oui.
Par contre, ce qui me pose problème,
aujourd'hui,
c'est l'attitude de certains,
qui sont dans l'invective,
dans la provocation...
-Dans le climat
global de l'hémicycle.
-Epouvantable.
-Vous avez été
la 1re présidente de la commission
des Affaires culturelles, en 2009 :
est-ce que la place des femmes,
en politique,
c'est pas mieux
aujourd'hui ?
-Oui, probablement. Mais je l'ai
jamais vécu comme un problème.
-Il n'y avait que 12 %
de femmes,
lors de votre 1er mandat,
et il y en a 3 fois plus
aujourd'hui.
Très peu, aussi,
de femmes-mères,
lorsque j'ai été élue maire,
à 32 ans.
Mais je dois dire
que je n'ai jamais
souffert de ça,
parce que j'ai...
mes convictions,
mon engagement, et je ne peux pas
dire qu'en étant une femme,
j'ai été brimée...
Mais je suis ravie... que
les femmes accèdent
aux fonctions
politiques et professionnelles.
-Pour finir :
40 ans d'engagement politique,
le secret
de votre longévité ?
-Je pense que je continue à faire
de la politique dans la proximité.
Voilà...
Je finis ma semaine à Paris,
j'arrive rapidement au Cannet,
dans ma circonscription,
Je vais voir mes électeurs,
je suis en contact
permanent...
-Ca vous fait durer.
-Je pense, oui.
C'est ce qui me fait comprendre
la France dans laquelle vit
et essayer de la défendre.
-Merci,
Michèle Tabarot,
de vous être confiée ici.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...